what is your fantasy soccer lineup so  who would I put in goal I don't know why  this is the first one that came to mind  LeBron I think he could do it he's just  that super athletic big guys I like his  chances and goals Center back  I don't know why I thought of this John  Cena he's got the build for it I think  okay let me think of a good Center man  in my brain as only athletes right now  so the one the one I said is Chris Paul  you know a bit of a distributor a good  IQ basketball could relate maybe so I  put him all right who's that Striker  who's going to be scoring the goals I'm  gonna put Justin Bieber up top I think  he can do the job  my favorite one of all time is Die In  Your Arms it's a throwback that was a  good song